Donald Trump has had an absolutely
disastrous week he's losing cabinet
members at record rates he's reportedly
shrunk into not doing a damn thing just
watching TV at the White House he had
only one hour of scheduled time a couple
of days ago and otherwise he had this
executive time we had the France
disaster over the weekend so what does
Trump do he calls a press event at the
White House fills the stage behind him
with black people to talk about criminal
justice reform to continue trying to
foment this idea that he is just the
best for black Americans but and and
this might actually surprise some of you
the reform that Trump is supporting
actually does contain some good things
except there's no chance that this is
actually going to get passed and the
timing of it is obvious political
grandstanding so I'll tell you about the
bill there's some bipartisan support for
this bill it's going to be almost
impossible to get the so-called
tough-on-crime conservatives to support
what is called the first-step Act some
of the things that the bill would do
loosen mandatory minimum sentencing laws
this is something that Trump's former
attorney general Jeff Sessions was very
much against but Jeff Sessions was fired
last week so who cares what Jeff
Sessions thinks anymore right lower
mandatory minimum sentences for drug
felonies reducing the three-strike
penalty from life in prison to 25 years
reducing the disparity in sentencing
between crack and powdered cocaine this
is a very racialized disparity crack is
more of a poor drug more prevalent in
non-white areas whereas powder cocaine
is the sort of middle-class version of
it more prevalent in white areas so that
that's a racial disparity that exists
this would reduce mandatory minimums
when a firearm is used during a violent
crime or a drug crime this gives judges
discretion to go below mandatory
minimums in certain cases it includes
some provisions to lower recidivism it
would place federal prisoner
closer to home it would allow for more
home confinement for lower-level
offenders
now coincidentally Donald Trump had
absolutely nothing to do with drafting
this legislation but that's okay it's
actually probably for the better so the
perspective on this is that the bill
does do some good things at the
micro-level it does nothing to deal with
the macro level of our prison system and
our justice system and incarceration
issues but the real problem for me Pat
is that this just III don't see how this
passes the House this year and this
Donald Trump's saying hey you know what
middle of November this is what I'm
going to do an announcement with black
people standing behind me for that's the
pandering
well maybe during the next congressional
session it would have a chance at
passing at the risk of being called
wide-eyed bushy-tailed naive Pat you
know maybe there is some hope here that
Trump will reach across the aisle he did
expressed some interest in working with
Nancy Pelosi congratulated her on taking
the house we had this suspicion when he
initially became president because he's
not ideologically tied down to the ideas
of the Republican Party so he thought
maybe he would reach across the aisle
then but then he went on to try to
repeal Obamacare and pass Republican tax
cuts for the rich so that then it ends
up happening but hey maybe there's a
chance now well listen the even if this
were to pass and I've made no I've not
hesitated to say that if Donald Trump
does something even coincidentally even
out of completely the wrong motivations
if he does something that I agree with
then I'll say hey here's something I
agree with does this change that this
was maybe one of the worst most
embarrassing weeks for Donald Trump of
his presidency no it does nothing to
change that does this change that most
likely nothing is actually going to be
passed under the current Congress and
thus choosing to make the announcement
with a big press conference with black
people behind him is a total optics play
it definitely doesn't change that but if
it passed there are some things in it
that wouldn't be bad send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
sustainability and workers rights are
issues that I talked about on the
program all the time which is why I'm
really glad that today's program is
sponsored by Fair indigo com who is
giving by the way our entire audience
15% off their first order when you use
the promo code Pakman at checkout Fair
indigo calm is a clothing company fully
committed to fair trade and eco-friendly
manufacturing and their clothing is made
from premium alpaca an ultra-high
quality pima cotton the softest and
longest lasting cotton on earth if
you're keeping track and it's grown by
small-scale farmers without any
pesticides and very importantly you've
heard me talk about this problem before
within the garment industry everything
fair indigo makes is made at a mill that
number one recycles 100% of its water
number two uses earth-friendly dyes and
most importantly arguably everything is
cut and sewn by experts at their Lima
Peru workshop where everybody is paid a
fair and living wage at fair indigo calm
you'll find a very nicely sized
selection for both men and women
t-shirts long-sleeve shirts polos
sweaters hoodies socks women's tops
dresses scarves and much more I right
now if you're watching on YouTube I'm
wearing the organic pima cotton t-shirt
it really is very soft and it always
feels good to buy clothes that are made
by people you know are earning a fair
wage and the quality of everything
unfair indigo calm is amazing click the
link under this video shipping is always
free on orders over $75 and you'll save
15% when you use the promo code PA que
ma n at checkout